علي عثمان ،
صباح الخير سيدي ، صباح الخير سيدي ، كيف
حالك ، لديك أربعة تذاكر لوقوف السيارات ، أنا سائق سيارة أجرة ،
لذلك عندما أخرج قبل أن أخرج
الساعة الرابعة صباحًا ، أحضر السيارة
أمام المنزل ، وأظلها تعمل
كما ترى  تذكرتي بعد الساعة الرابعة
وحتى أرتدي ملابسي لذا أخرج من
أين أنت يا سيدي
أصلاً أنا من مصر سيدي لكنني
هنا منذ عام 1994. أوه أنت من
مصر نعم
سيدي وأنت  سائق سيارة أجرة الآن ، نعم سيدي ،
عليك استخدام نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي أو هل تعرف
كل الشوارع ،
وأنا أعلم ما هو وقت الذهاب إلى الفراش الآن ولكن
كل هذه السنوات تعمل
ولكني أعرف وقت الذهاب إلى الفراش ،
وأنا أعلم في كل مكان يا سيدي ، منذ متى
وأنت تقود سيارتك  سيارة أجرة
منذ عام 2004. نعم ، لقد تغيرت كثيرًا
، فهي تفعل ما هو التغيير قبل
أوبر وبعد كورونا قبل
كورونا في الواقع معظم الأعمال الآن
في المطار
لأن المطار خرج عن
العمل بالفعل
ولا شيء خارج القطار لا شيء في
فندق
أنهم من الصعب جدًا العثور على وظيفة
في وسط المدينة يا أخي  الآن
يا سيد أوزمان ، سأمنحك استراحة
من تذاكر وقوف السيارات ، هذا لطيف جدًا ،
أنت رجل مجتهد أتيت من
مصر وتحاول كسب لقمة العيش
هنا في الولايات المتحدة ، أنت
صعب  - أيها الرجل العامل ، لقد أتيت إلى هنا
مثل الملايين والملايين من الناس
قبل أن تأتي إلى هنا من بلد آخر ،
هل لديك أطفال ،
نعم لدي سبعة أطفال ،
نعم جميعهم جيدون ،
لقد تخرجوا ، شكرًا لأمريكا ، لقد
كنت أعمل بجد  كما قلت
وأنا أدفع مقابل كليتهم ، لقد فعلت الكثير من
أجلهم وكلهم جيدون الآن بشكل جيد ، أنت
تمثل بلدك الأصلي جيدًا
وقد قمت بعمل رائع في هذا
البلد ، لذا شكرًا جزيلاً لك
الفضل للولايات المتحدة حظًا سعيدًا
لك ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك ،
وأنا أقدر مساعدتك
[موسيقى]